[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
here's a story of three dudes named Alan
who all threw the football pretty well
and then one Sunday thanks to injuries
they all started in the NFL one in
Denver one in Carolina and of course one
in Chile Buffalo and all these dudes
named Alan became when Q pees don't you
know but here on your fantasy fire drill
there's still one question in our queue
these three dudes all named Alan what is
their fantasy value the Alan's Josh
Brendan Kyle Allen do deulim receivers
but one's a starter what's the fantasy
value of the alien dude find out right
now on your fantasy fire drill
why from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace to Fabulous Las Vegas it's your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
thank goodness I wasn't the one singing
welcome into your fantasy fire drill i
am matt camp it is week ten in the
National Football League and we have you
covered as we do each and every Sunday
11:30 Eastern 8:30 Pacific on all
bleacher report platforms and right here
at the sports book in Caesars now if you
want to join us you can do it there and
I'll be jumping in the app as soon as
the show is over to take more of your
questions for an extra bonus 30 minutes
but right now we jump into the show what
are we gonna have ins and outs the
injuries
there's a bunch today sorry we have your
sleepers we'll get to plenty of your
questions will even take a look at the
fantasy marketplace all of that coming
your way as we make the push to the
fantasy playoffs but it's gonna be a
bumpy ride with six teams on the by
coating the Eagles and the Patriots and
all of these injuries let's get to your
eaves and out for the early game I warn
you it's an ugly list and hopefully it's
gonna get better
Marquis Brown and Lamar Jackson both on
the injury report this week no official
word but they should be good to go
obviously you're playing them with
confidence today AJ Green we're gonna
talk about injury optimism saying why
you shouldn't have it they hung on to
him you don't have them this week and
who knows when we'll see him he is out
fairly didn't look too good warm-ups
this morning either so who knows what
he's coming back and the big story of
the day Matthew Stafford is out today
for the Detroit Lions he has broken
bulbs and is back again Adam last year
has them in a different spot apparently
today Jeff Driskel is your starting
quarterback for the Detroit Lions a
little bit of a downgrade for Kenny Gala
day and of course for Marvin Jones as
well Corey Davis was listed as doubtful
he is out today kind of a bummer but I
do you it does give me a little bit more
reason to take a look at AJ Brown more
targets could be coming core AJ Browns
way with Corey Davis out against the
Kansas City Chiefs now the Battle of New
York New Jersey bad teams whatever
MetLife Stadium it will not have Evan
Engram the foot issues continue to be a
problem he is week to week and sterling
Shepherds concussions remain an issue
there now I'll tell you this we're gonna
get the sleepers coming up but Evan
Engram take a look at Rhett Ellison it
will be the tight end for the Giants
today and then Darius Layton's been
coming through I love Golden Tate today
but Darius
has been coming through for the Giants
and connecting with Daniel Jones now who
will they play in this game
Le'Veon Bell and Chris Herndon no
official word yet Bell tweeted out on
Saturday he's playing he's good to go
a Herndon was active last week but was
more of an emergency active he should be
making his debut today I'm still staying
away from him now your late game
inactives
injuries what we know right now
obviously we can't lock a lot of this
stuff in but things we do know we know
Brandon cooks also dealing with
concussions he is out he wasn't the
practice field this week late in the
week so hopefully there's a good sign
there but I never expect anything when
it comes to concussion timelines James
Connor is gonna be out again this week
we will see Jalen Samuels now I will
note and I talked to Jalen Samuels last
week I'm a radio show that you're gonna
see Trey Edmonds we did see him get
carries I feel better about Jalen
Samuels in PPR formats because he's
catching a bunch of passes and I do
think that will continue juju should
play Diana Rossini report from ESPN this
morning noted while he's listed as
questionable
he's expected to play we know it's kind
of been a bummer to deal with him this
season now couple things we know later
on T Y Hilton and Jacoby Brissette are
both out today now you'll see a sleeper
wide receiver from the Colts I am
sticking with we'll get to that coming
up Brian Hoyer maybe a real deep sleeper
option he's got the Dolphins today we
know it's him DFS plays he's a cheap one
Adam Thielen is out injury optimism like
I said we'll talk a lot about it on the
show today tried to come back last week
banged up not gonna see him tonight
maybe he continues to sit out as well in
that game also Amari Cooper had MRI this
week he's okay he's gonna manage his
injury we expect to see him tonight but
I do have a little pause about that when
we're talking about managing these
injuries and if you're dealing with any
of these banged up players this week you
know what that's all about
Matt Breda I think he's always on this
list he should be okay but George Kittel
is listed as doubtful now Kyle Shanahan
I appreciate the honest he said if it
was anybody else we would likely already
be ruling out George kill because it's
George Kittel he's their best player
they're not sure yet now I don't think
he's going to play they want to take it
down to the wire if you have George
Kittel and you have no other options if
you try to put them in the Flex and
pivot away to anybody else in that game
okay but if you don't and you have to
make a call before tomorrow
don't risk the zero with George Kindle
because doesn't look like he's gonna
play Josh Gordon just arriving to
Seattle I don't think he has a ton of
value anyway I think he's a luxury for
them and he's banged up Tyler Lockett
should be out there that's what we know
as of right now and we have some
breaking news on being told in my ear
LeSean McCoy will not play today for the
Chiefs so there you go some breaking
news right there and we're gonna talk
about LeSean McCoy in just a little bit
but let Sean McCoy is out that's an easy
bump right there to Damian Williams who
I am back on board with we'll talk about
McCoy coming up but there you go some
breaking news
LeSean McCoy is inactive today for the
Chiefs against the Titans now let's get
to your questions
and I'm sure there's plenty out there
for this week with all the byes and
injuries and all that so let's jump in
to your questions here as we try to
cover everything not only for week 10
but all of it for your line of
questioning let's see what we have here
in just there we go a full point PPR OB
yet go BJ Devante Parker or Zach Pascal
I'll stick with Beckham I don't love it
but you know one of those guys gets me
too excited at all stick with Beckham
there for Daniel Lee next question retro
is latavius Murray a viable start to
speak with camara back look I said this
is the beginning of the season I'll
stick to it now with camara coming back
from injury I always felt like latavius
Murray could be thrown in as a flex
option and I'll throw this in game flow
could be in a saber today
I think the Saints will beat up the
Falcons late in the game you see more of
Murray to run the clock out why waste
Tamara with those meaningless snaps for
him there you go well Josh Allen target
downfield enough for me to start our
John Brown yeah he will I'm also not
worried about that John Brown has been a
rock-solid wide receiver to and it's not
just haven't been about downfield passes
so yeah six for seven they're gonna play
John Brown today Kyle Emery versus Tampa
mahomes turning against Tennessee look
hold me back he's not even on the injury
report
we're playing the Holmes and you start
him until further notice continue on
here Dean Allen said I play foyer darn
'old or Daniel Jones
I don't mind any of these guys this week
is a cheap DFS play but Daniel Jones is
ranked highest on my board we'll get
some more of him later on
she's the against the Titans with
phonatory Davis we're Rams be against
Pittsburgh I'm gonna take a look at the
Ramsey because the Pittsburgh offense
scare me too much but now we take a
question in the wall hey guys this is TJ
this week is my league's trade deadline
and I've got an offer on the table the
other guy wants to send me DJ check for
Marlon Mac I could use a little bit of
wide receiver depth but I'm just not
sure what's gonna happen with the
quarterback situation in Jacksonville
can you give me some help well we're
gonna see Nick Foles back soon enough
but I'll say this I wouldn't make that
deal
I probably anyway just in a vacuum value
Marlon Macklemore DJ Tarkan DJ trucks
been great I've been singing this praise
that I won't stop doing that but there
is a quarterback chain is there I mean
did have a rapport with gardner minshew
i'll also say this he talked about the
idea of getting more wide receiver depth
I'd rather have runningback depth we're
gonna reach it to that runningback depth
each and every week as soon as we as
soon as later we get into the season
you're gonna need those running back so
that's a one-for-one trade that's really
just moving the points around your
lineup I'm just gonna stick with Marlon
Mac they're fair question though those 1
for 1 deals they don't seem to work out
too great that often it's a good
question
there's no London game there's I don't
know don't do that don't work on your
Robert Taft no that's all that's a babe
I know don't work thank you though not
by you never work on your Robert Kraft
especially not in public
all right here's we do now we'll give
you some stock stock it's time for the
Tennessee stockings
[Music]
I feel like I kind of told the future in
one of these we'll get to that a little
bit so as we move towards your playoff
push it's week ten double-digit weeks
we're probably about three four weeks
here before you start your fantasy
playoffs you got to know who you can
trust
maybe to go trade with a trade deadline
coming up and maybe some players to move
away from whether it be cutting them
putting them on your bench or maybe
making a trade to get them off your team
let's start with who's up who's up he
got out of Denver he is in San Francisco
he's gonna help your fantasy team he's
gonna help the Niners as well it's a
manual Sanders he's had a great first
two games with the Niners we'll see him
against the Seahawks this week another
matchup that looks pretty good to me
especially with George Cato banged up
and he goes from a mess in Denver to a
better situation in San Francisco we
love Kyle Shanahan he's the coach of
this show he's the official coach of
your fantasy fire drill and Jimmy
Garoppolo has done a good job at a big
game against Arizona last week and
Emmanuel Sanders was a big part of that
Emmanuel Sanders now to me is a
rock-solid wide receiver too they needed
somebody who was head and shoulders
above the rest of that wide receiver
group in San Francisco and they got it
in a manual Sanders they'll help the
Niners go far and will help your fantasy
team go far as well now to the flipside
of this
who's gonna hurt your team if you're
trying to rely on them we tried to get
this right carry out Johnson down he's
out for the week 16 so oh look there's a
starting running back spot available but
no one's taking that spot no one is
grasping that roll and the Lions aren't
sticking with one guy Trey Carson see
you off the IR not even on the team
anymore mckissick and Ty Johnson look
today against the Bears I'm not excited
about it anyway now no Stafford out
there probably hurts the offense in
general you just can't trust anybody in
this backfield because for some reason
the Lions don't want to stick with one
of these players if they can't stick
with one of these players neither can
you now back to the flipside who's on
the way up in the world as we move into
the playoff push it's Devin Singletary
of the Buffalo Bills
I've had to adjust my thoughts I thought
the young rookie would maybe in the
later parts of the season get more looks
because the bills would be out of it
well quite the opposite the bills are
right in this thing at six and two and
the bills are realizing while they have
a future hall-of-famer who's still
playing at a high level in Frank Gore
this is a guy who takes our office
next level he's gonna raise the ceiling
for the bills and they're smart enough
to say hey instead of just being a
wildcard team maybe we can be more than
that and if we can more be more than
that with Devin Singletary if they stick
with them and I think they will
Devin Singletary can help you win a
fantasy championship this season
everybody asked me for league winners
you might have one right there in Devin
Singletary now a former Buffalo Bill who
we broke some news on earlier in the
show is on the downs and it's LeSean
McCoy so not even listed on the injury
report today and inactive giving me all
more reason by the way this was ready
like two days ago to tell you he's on
his way down and I had initially full
transparency the entire Chiefs backfield
on this list singled it down to McCoy
and feel a lot better about that now I
also feel better about Damian Williams
being the man in the Kansas City Chiefs
backfield going forward and you feel
better about the offense anyway because
Patrick mahomes is back so McCoy is now
a bench option at best in your smaller
leagues
get rid of them you don't need them now
back to the ups and we go young again
and we go young with one of my guys this
was my favorite rookie wide receiver and
man he is coming through I wrote him up
big time last week and he crushed it
DK Metcalf and let me get something
straight here Josh Gordon does not scare
me when it comes to DK Metcalf Josh
Gordon wasn't doing anything with Tom
Brady in New England and that wasn't a
deep receiving core I'd even argue I'm
not even gonna argue I'm gonna tell you
it's a fact
Seattle's receiving core is better than
New England's receiving core so why
should I be worried about Josh Gordon
infiltrating and taking touches away
from Metcalf and Lockett keep playing
this guy with confidence because he's
playing with the NFL MVP right now in
Russell Wilson alright one more
on the downside for the fantasy
marketplace as we wrap things up here as
al Shawn Jeffery and honestly this could
be the all Philadelphia Eagle wide
receiver group but you're not playing
any of them anyway except for al Sean
who's now become a lineup decision he's
not catching the ball Carsten Lance is
playing great
it hurts came back last week in a big
way god it's been solid miles Sanders
has been good but else on Jeffery even
though he's the number one receiver in
Philadelphia making too many mistakes
and I might be able to run faster than
him right now so not a lot to be in your
lineup and certainly not somebody you
feel good about playing at any week they
need to rebound and he's poor
that he's on his way down there's your
fantasy marketplace but now we get to
more of your question let's do so right
now Kyle please help Singletary Sanders
our Kirk I think Sanders is probably the
safest with the most up side against
Seattle offense the defense this week so
go with him Jonathan Smith Howard a
christening and Bergman I'm gonna go
John who Smith against the Chiefs hoping
for a lot of points in that game in
Tennessee playing from behind
tough call start Winston or breeze I'm
starting breezy played great last week
no worries in the world about the injury
and he's got the Falcons one of the best
matchups you can possibly have nice spot
to be and when you got two good
quarterbacks there jaylen Samuels or
David Montgomery I believe this is
America's fantasy question this week
because everybody's asked me this in a
PPR I slightly favor Samuels but I say
Dave Montgomery has more upside if you
think you need it against a very
beatable Lions run defense next one up
here it's factory packaging Kelsey or
Hooper with Lindsey a good idea to trade
for a big-time wide receiver
I'm not moving Kelsey because the
big-time wide receiver is basically
Travis Kelce now if you do who for at
Lindsey and get a big-time wide receiver
that is a deal I would make next one up
here should I drop Josh Gordon first Anu
absolutely sinuhe's actually playing and
involved in his offense in New England
Josh Gordon is a luxury player for the
Seahawks and they have two better
receivers in front of them go to the
wall for a celebrity question from Shane
hey man I'm really bad at fantasy
football but for some reason I'm second
in my league so maybe it's divorce
league in the world who do I start this
week Kyle Allen or sand Arnold I think
that's their names
well you say he's not good at it that's
shame Thank You Shane Torres for the
question the Allen brothers they all won
last week but I'll stay away from this
week I liked Arnold I'm okay with I
don't love them
but Donald against the Giants look bad
Giants defense bad jet defense tells me
a lot of points to be had it might be
ugly but well it takes four quarters to
get there who cares if he throws a
couple of touchdowns and goes 300 yards
and maybe there's an interception or two
along the way hey that comes the
territory but I'll play the matchup and
I'll do so it's Sam Donald's and we'll
get into more of that matchup coming up
because right now it's time for my week
10 sleepers
[Music]
all right sleeper time and we were just
talking about that matchup we're gonna
break one of my rules because well it's
obvious to do so the tight end position
is a mess I talked about retina or
Ellison earlier being a good option
let's look at this tight end right here
we're gonna go to Miami not stay away
from Miami for once Mike gets icky this
is all about opportunity they have the
Colts today that's not a matchup that
scares me but opportunity is there
Kenyan Drake's in Arizona Kaelin balázs
stinks Mark Walton just got suspended
for four games so he's out of the mix
Preston Williams has been their best
receiver he's out for the season
there's targets available and Micah
sticky is coming off his best and
busiest game of the season last week so
why not go back to him I'm not saying
he's anything special but we're hunting
and begging and pleading for help at the
tight end position you might find it
this week in Micah city he's got a top
12 weaken him and I ranked him as such
that Giants Jets came I'll put my money
where my mouth is and tell you that
Daniel Jones is a viable starter this
week he always can run we like that
there's been a couple weeks where he's
come through he's got the Jets he's not
at home well technically he is but
technically well you know what they're
at MetLife and they're there he didn't
have to travel this week the Jets
defense is very beatable I know they
don't know if Shepard I don't know I
know they don't have anger him but
golden Tate's their Barclays their
Ellison's fine slate he's connected with
I take a look at Daniel Jones this week
I think he's got top 12 potential
against the very beatable shi'ites
defense now one more and I'm sticking
with this one despite what's going on a
quarterback it's Zach Pascal I gave his
AK Pascal last week went ey Hilton was
down he came through and he came through
with who Brian Hoyer Brian Hoyer is
starting for the Colts today so I'll go
right back to Zach Pascal here we'll go
back to the rule we'll follow the
Dolphins Pascal against the Dolphins
today notes ey Hilton coiours certainly
a viable option as a starting
quarterback and a cheap play DFS but you
can go with Zach Pascal this week don't
forget that sleepers article comes out
every Friday got the full list there for
you and I gave you a couple bonus ones
but now YouTube we're going to use we're
going to you right now it's a YouTube
section of questions Jimmy or Brady
we're gonna play well Brady's out this
week so it's obviously not Brady next
you got to pay attention to matchups
Marie or Prescott we're gonna go with
Marie it's close
so Prescott men against Minnesota scares
me a little bit there for Ethan next
question Sonne I've been skittle he's
doubtful if you don't have a pivot if
you can put them in your Flex spot and
hold off until Monday night to make a
call on them I would do that but if you
have to make the call today make the
call today you don't want to risk the
zero with Kidal if you have a back up
tight end on your roster I do but I may
be moving away from that soon as we get
over the bye weeks it's not bad to have
if you don't have a locked in starter if
you have Kelsey early these big names I
don't care about the back-up side edge
next question
obj or John Brown is a standard League
flex Joe my man you got to go with John
Brown and sorry about your charters that
did not go so well the other night
next one lay beyond Beller Derrick Henry
at Flex I'll go at lay beyond Bell
I don't expect Henry to catch another
touchdown so now I'll go with lay beyond
Bell but now we go out to the sports but
people get up early here in Vegas it's
it's not even 9:00 a.m. on the East
Coast I know it's later but I got to
help people out that show up here as
well hello Kelly what's up I need lots
of help with my fantasy team okay look
I've got David Johnson David Montgomery
and they both shown lots of promise but
I need to get that playoff push on three
and six and I know that's a terrible
record but the good news is there's
other guys in my division that are two
and seven so I have an outside shot to
make the playoffs okay I need to pick up
a new running back is Kareem Hunt out
there
Kareem hunt is not out there oh boy I'm
wondering if I could make a trade for mo
see how he does today get him on the
cheap now because I think he can might
be playing a bigger role in the offense
and I would give up the world to get
Devin Singletary on my team okay watch
Kelly on the betting show she's coming
up next thanks Kelly
thanks all right there you go all right
after all that piano music playing
here's a matte moment
hey I'm at camp professional fantasy
football prognosticator people ask me
all the time Matt you help me with my
fantasy team but can you help me play a
real football you're damn right I can
because with my VHS tape Matt camp
teaches real football I'll have you in
my fantasy starting lineup in no time
we'll work on skills like throwing
kicking you idiot you broke my nail
catching that's how you do it like a pro
and tackling what NFL player who refuses
to be named says I watch this video for
five minutes and then I turned it off
the sports cassette says this video is
terrible
Matt camp must owe someone a lot of
money
[Music]
so you get all upside when you buy
something that doesn't turn out to be
great
you gotta manage your expectations and
that brings us to injury optimism if you
haven't learned about injury optimism
this week you never will look at all the
names we'll get back to in just a second
that are banged up we're trying to come
back last week I'll give you an example
injury optimism I had DeSean Jackson and
AJ Green on my team on Monday I traded
them both away to get DK Metcalf and I
got laughed at who's laughing now I
treated for the healthy player on a
playoff contending team Adam Phelan
tried to come back didn't happen to Sean
Jackson
AJ Green you name it don't have that
injury optimism when these guys do come
back don't expect them to play at the
highest of levels cuz you'll burn
yourself health is very important as we
move down the stretch all right back to
inactives speaking those injuries and
optimism what's going out the window
let's see where we're at what everything
marques Browns in Lamar Jackson's in for
the Ravens you're rolling with those
guys today just talked about injury
often was a Jay Green I don't know when
we're gonna see him again
you might be thinking you're small
leagues about cutting a Matthew Stafford
this came out today
he's got broken bones in his back Jeff
Driscoll's your starter for the Lions
you got a downgrade a gala day you got
to downgrade Marvin Jones Corey Davis is
out today which gives me a little bit
more confidence to play AJ Brown against
the Kansas City Chiefs
Johnny Smith as well Evan Engram
sterling Shepherd both down for the
Giants take a look at red Ellison take a
look at Derry slate and I love Golden
Tate this week maybe on bells in and
Chris Herndon in as well and by the way
this is not a fake and active or active
for Herndon he's actually gonna play
today don't have a ton of confidence now
late-game inactive is what we know right
now just so you can prepare accordingly
cooks concussion out Josh Reynolds the D
play James Connors out I liked Jalen
Samuels and PPR juju should play
according to an ESPN report but we know
he's in that low and wide receiver to
conversation hilt now preset out Brian
Hoyer is a freebie in DFS Hylton I take
a look at Zack Pascal Adam feeling is
out I don't want to go play laQuan
Treadwell if you're asking Amari Cooper
should play through his knee issue we
should see Matt Breda on Monday night
obviously you have to have in Coleman
their deal with Kittel is doubtful if
you don't have a pivot on Monday night
take them out of your lineup don't risk
the 0 I don't care about Josh Gordon and
Tyler Lockett
should be out there so there you go we
did all that and we got a move
quickly it's time for the speed round
[Music]
could be a very quick speed round here
Co tight where are you I can see it at
the camo on you-know-who myself SAP
camel on is obj you know I don't know
Baker Mayfield kids by him I'm here all
week let's get this me drown make sure
they feel tips on feeling too good
inside info for you alright Jalen
Samuels David Johnson or Devin
Singletary I think I just vents David
Johnson's I think any Jake will still be
in the mix Meg Griffin Matt freed are
Auden Kate we're gonna go mad free to
their I don't care about the Bengals
receivers should I trade Eckler for
curry mutton Hollywood round yeah I'm
okay with that move because Eckler is
settling back into that Flex low and rb2
spot their next one drew brees our dak
breeze against the south let's fire that
one up and do so with confidence Alan
Robinson or gallop I don't like the
match for delegates Minnesota will go
down Robinson against the Detroit Lions
the sticky boot off hook waiver wire
pick up I like Jared cooks back with
Drew Brees against the very beatable
Falcons defense today so let's go back
to Jared Cook Amendola Mixon I'm not
going to get too few with this let's
just play Joe Mixon and we'll know the
next one I start Winston Rogers and
Rogers baby all day long keep firing up
Aaron Rodgers Josh Allen are cousins I
like talked down against the Browns
today bunts against Dallas on the road I
don't love that one keep going
char free the locket for Berkeley reader
Ridley and Sanders who I like them
getting Barclay and Sanders there and I
wonder if sharks value as already teak
so there you go
those are your questions and I'm jumping
in the app for another half-hour of
questions for you so get in there with
me and join me will you every single
Sunday on all bleacher report platform
8:30 Pacific 11:30 Eastern right here on
your fantasy fire drill i'm matt camp
good luck to you in week 10